أعتقد أنه في المرة الأولى
التي تنظر فيها إلى فرس البحر كنت
مفتونًا به ، فهي تقريبًا
أسماك أسطورية من الآلهة القديمة ، والآن
يلتقي حوض السمك المفضل مع ذيل النمر والقنفذ
والأقزام بعضًا من 46 نوعًا معروفًا
من فرس البحر
التي كافح العلماء
لتحديدها بسبب خبرتهم في
التمويه الذي يساعدهم على
تجنب الحيوانات المفترسة
[الموسيقى
] يغيرون لونهم عندما يحكمون
بتكوين روابط زوجية دائمة يجتمع الذكور
والإناث معًا ويرقصون كل
صباح ،
أعني أن هذه الحيوانات هي أروع
الأسماك التي هم عليها  حقًا
[موسيقى]
أحد الحيوانات المفترسة التي لم تتمكن خيول البحر
من تجنبها
هو البشر الذين يتعرضون لموائلهم في الشعاب المرجانية
والأعشاب البحرية وأشجار المانغروف في جميع أنحاء
العالم
لتهديد متزايد ، وأكبر تهديد فردي
لخيول البحر هو الصيد بشباك الجر
كل يوم مئات الآلاف  من
سفن الصيد تتخلص من قاع المحيط
وتزيل كل شيء في طريقها
تاركة وراءها دمارًا
ورائها الإبادة والصيد نقيًا
وبسيطًا  le ويجب أن تتوقف عن
[موسيقى]
أماندا فنسنت هي ناشطة في
مجال الحفاظ على البيئة البحرية وأحد الخبراء الرائدين في العالم في
مجال فرس البحر ، وأعتقد أنني
أحب فرس البحر في اللحظة التي اكتشفت فيها
أن الذكر فقط هو الذي يحمل ، وهناك
شيء ما حول ذلك يمسك بك
وقد قضته  أكثر من 30 عامًا من دراسة
هذه المخلوقات الصغيرة
بشخصيات كبيرة ،
عادةً ما نطلب من الناس عدم لمس
فرس البحر إذا رأيته ، لكن كان علي أن
ألمسهم في عملي المهني وهو
ما يلفت انتباهك دغدغة
ذيولهم الصغيرة ويتخلون عن كل ما
يفعلونه  إنهم يمسكون بيدك وهم يمسكون بيدك
بدلاً من ذلك ،
أعني متى كانت آخر سمكة
ممسكة بيدك ، فقط لتشعر
بارتفاع فوري في الاتصال مع هذا
الحيوان الذي
شارك في تأسيسه فنسنت في مشروع seahorse في
عام 1996 ،
وهي منظمة للحفظ والبحوث
التي تقوم بحملات من أجل أقوى  اللوائح
الخاصة بممارسات الصيد
وتجارة الأحياء البرية ، وقد نجحوا
في
تغيير التشريعات الوطنية والدولية
للمساعدة في حماية فرس البحر
ووضعها  35 منطقة بحرية محمية
في الفلبين ،
موطنًا لعشرة أنواع من خيول البحر
خلال بحثها ، كشفت Vinson عن
تجارة عالمية ضخمة في فرس البحر
عنصرًا شائعًا في الطب الصيني في
جميع أنحاء العالم
بما في ذلك موطنها الأصلي كندا ، حيث
قمنا بإحصاء ما يصل إلى 20 30 مليون
حيوان سنويًا بين  حوالي 80 دولة
كانت ضخمة
من حيث عدد الحيوانات الفردية التي يتم
تداولها ، إنها واحدة من أكبر تجارة الحياة البرية
حتى الآن ،
لذا كان من المهم حقًا اتخاذ
إجراء ، ثم أنشأنا أول
ضوابط تصدير على الإطلاق للأسماك البحرية والتي
أدت إلى الكثير من البلدان في الواقع
إغلاق تجارة فرس البحر
بشكل قانوني
بعد حملة صليبية طوال حياتها ضد
أساليب الصيد الضارة
، تبحث فنسنت دائمًا عن
بدائل مستدامة
وتجدها هنا في قرية
ستيفستون في فانكوفر ، لقد حصلت على قريدس
تم اصطياده بواسطة الفخاخ لا تدمير موطن
لا  المصيد العرضي للحيوانات الأخرى هم
الروبيان الوحيد الذي أكلته على الإطلاق ،
لذا عندما كان هؤلاء الرجال
يستجوبون أين  تأتي المأكولات البحرية الخاصة بك
من إحدى الطرق للمساعدة في حماية الحياة البحرية ،
يقول فنسنت إنه
إذا كان بإمكانك تجنب تناول أي شيء
مرتبط بشباك الجر في قاع البحر ، فستكون
قد قدمت خدمة رائعة للمحيط
[موسيقى
] وبالنسبة لفينسنت ، فإن خدمة المحيط تعني
جعلنا نقع في حب  هذه
المخلوقات الأسطورية الغامضة
أجد أنه عندما تتحدث عن فرس البحر ، فإن
الجميع يهتم بشكل
أساسي ، فنحن نستخدم خيول البحر
للمساعدة في إنقاذ البحار إذا حصلنا عليها بشكل صحيح
لهذه الأسماك الصغيرة غير التقليدية ،
فسنكون قد فعلنا الكثير للمحيط
أنت